hey youtubers this Charlie so big news
Doctor Who is coming back tonight this
is gonna be a video all about who I want
the next companion to be so just careful
for spoilers some subset was set in the
media Jenna Coleman Steven Moffat the
BBC people have said some things so
what's happened is Jenna Coleman went on
the one show yesterday morning it
announced that she was actually leaving
the TARDIS at the end of series 9 now it
wasn't a huge surprise she said for her
because she and Moffat apparently about
a year and a half ago picked an end
point for her character and just said
this is where we're gonna try and exit
so it sounds like for a long time Moffat
has known when he's gonna need to
introduce a new companion so I wouldn't
be surprised if he already knows who it
is and they've cast them there are a
couple options right off the bat they
could introduce the companion in a brief
cameo during the Christmas special this
year or they could wait till series 10
episode 1 now the BBC announced that
River Song would be coming back for the
Christmas special we don't know what
that story's gonna be
but obviously the story is gonna be
central to her and the doctor so I'm not
expecting them to Jam a new companion in
there but they could totally do that
I would totally lose my if River
Song regenerated in the new river became
the doctor's companion but I don't think
that's gonna happen
Moffat does a lot of crazy stuff but
that just sounds a little too nuts Alex
Kingston is just too perfect as River
Song right now it's kind of the same
deal with Missy we're probably not gonna
see Missy regenerate into a new master
anytime soon Michelle Gomez the actress
that she's totally happy to continue
playing the character for forever
and I think it's kind of nice that
certain actors overlap when doctors and
companions change it it helps to kind of
close the gaps in continuity so it's
like well get a new companion in series
10 Capaldi will probably come back and
then that new companion will get a new
doctor and it'll just kind of bridge the
gap what about new companions though I
feel like there are a couple obvious fan
picks that may not end up happening but
that we have to talk about right off the
bat Maisie Williams just at that right
point in her career where she isn't
doing films all the time and she's on
another TV series that only does 10
episodes a year so she does have time to
squeeze another TV series in there as
long as it doesn't run for too long now
Moffat has said that her character is
like a one-off thing she's not supposed
to recur but rule number one of Doctor
Who is that Moffat lies so pay no
attention to that and for those that are
wondering about how Game of Thrones
overlaps
with dr. who during the year usually
Game of Thrones doesn't start filming
til the end of the summer and that's
around the time when dr. who stops
filming the only exception to that is
the Christmas special and it's pretty
easy to get to Cardiff from where Game
of Thrones shoots now that I mean they
should in Ireland in a couple different
places like Spain but it's not a huge
leap to assume that you'd be able to
take a week or so off from Game of
Thrones to come film an episode of
Doctor Who if she needed to and that's
only the Christmas special and if you
remember like voyage of the Damned
sometimes companions don't even appear
in the Christmas special so from a
scheduling standpoint there's nothing
holding up Maisie Williams from being
the new companion I think it's more a
question of whether or not she wants to
do another TV series with that extra
time that she has during the year or if
she wants to do more features moving
along next big game of Thrones actors
Fame are say if you remember Shona from
the Christmas special last year she's
only a minor character on Game of
Thrones so I think it'd be much much
easier for her to do two series at once
especially if the dates don't overlap
but during the Christmas specials she
just felt like one of those characters
that was waiting for the TARDIS to show
up outside her door and say hey where do
you want to go anywhere in time and
space just look at her apartment here
her life just looks super boring she
definitely looks like the kind of person
who would be totally down to go with the
doctor
usually that's what you see with the
younger human companions it's like
they're stuck in some sort of
existential rut that the doctor comes
along and helps work them out of and
then once they do they they mature
they're like okay I need to get on with
my life thank you doctor I'm gonna go
back it has to be said though this is
still Moffitt's run so whenever
companions leave it usually ends up
being like the most horrible cry worthy
way possible so I'm definitely expecting
something like that to happen with Jenna
Coleman just look at the titles for this
series I feel like Moffat heard all the
jokes about how he terrorizes children
and turn it into a literal thing like
he's writing the episode titles to tell
you what he's going to do to you this
year what about non-human companions
though there's science abra from series
8 they were a lot of fun during time
heist and it seemed like they worked
well with the doctor they had a nice
energy some you guys were commenting on
my last Doctor Who video that you wanted
to see the next companion come from
somewhere besides earth what about a
male companion though I did see some
suggestions from other Emmerdale actors
now I'm not super familiar with that
show I haven't been watching it but
Jenna Coleman was on it it's been
running for a long time so that mean
there's a ton of actors that have been
on it but I did see Danny Miller's
suggestion and he actually seems like a
pretty solid choice and someone with a
little bit more edge than Rory had Rory
was kind of the soft one Amy Pond was
the one with the edge and the other
actress that I think could probably do a
really good job would be a filial of a
bond who was awesome on Elementary I
don't know that she's going back on that
show because they shoot almost all year
long like if she did another season of
elementary there's no way she'd be able
to do a season two Doctor Who she did a
really good job of bringing a bit of
darkness to her character and that's
kind of what I'd like to see in the next
companion you guys can let me know
though who do you want the next
companion to be and what do you want
their dynamic to be with the doctor like
do you want it to be a younger character
like you want it to be like Maisie
Williams and be like a young girl with
an old man or do you want to see an
older male companion or an older female
or do you want to see River Song do you
want to see River Song be the next
companion that feels like it'd almost be
fanservice just like a little too much
so here's what's gonna happen with my
series 9 videos tonight episode one's
gonna air I'll post my video after so be
sure to subscribe to get it and I'll be
doing a new round of the giveaway I'm
gonna be doing a weekly Doctor Who
giveaway just like I did last year if
you guys want to follow me on Twitter
and Facebook there are links for that in
the description I will be live tweeting
a little bit during the British
broadcast when it's on the BBC now it
airs on BBC America about eight hours
after that so I'm not gonna be doing
super spoilery stuff but if you guys
want it's gonna be there my video should
post by the time the American broadcast
starts so if you're watching it in
America you'll be able to watch it like
right after you get done watching the
episode so everybody get hype there's
gonna be a whole bunch of classic who
Easter eggs in the first two episodes so
be sure to keep your eyes peeled while
you guys wait for that you can click
here for the last trailer and you can
click here to learn all about the
prequel episode it was like a just like
a short five minute episode thank you so
much watching everybody looks at five
I'll see you guys